how do men have a privilege how do men  have privilege when they're the majority  of suicides when they do the majority of  hard jobs they have to fight in Wars  okay so so okay  I I think that if what you're asking and  what we're gonna have to talk about is  where men have privileges then we're not  going to be able to have this argument  with this this debate we're not going to  be able to talk about this because we're  just simply not on the same level of  understanding about society as a whole  if you're unable to understand that men  have privilege in the majority of cases  and that there is an underlying  privilege that all men have a by nature  of a patriarchy